votar conduce a la realización de tus
demandas repetían a través de unos
altavoces las fuerzas de seguridad
iraquíes en un intento para incentivar
el voto en los comicios legislativos que
se celebrarán este domingo en irak y que
están marcados por el descontento social
y la desconfianza política
yo no votaré porque los resultados no
serán creíbles no creo que estas
elecciones sean libres y honestas y no
creo que un iraquí honorable pueda ser
candidato entre otros grupos porque
todos son unos fracasados y no aman a su
país ni son leales sino que quieren
regalarlo
a la corrupción y la mala gestión de los
partidos tradicionales han hecho que
miles de iraquíes se nieguen a acudir a
las urnas mientras los expertos
pronostican que la clase política
mantendrá su control del poder
y los resultados de las elecciones
iraquíes se conocen y es un juego en el
que las clases políticas se turnan y se
reparten los ministerios entre ellos así
como el primer ministerio la presidencia
el parlamento y la presidencia está
claro cada cuatro años rotan
las elecciones se celebran un año antes
de lo previsto debido a las masivas
protestas antigubernamentales que
sacudieron el país en 2019 cuando
millones de jóvenes salieron a las
calles para exigir mejoras democráticas
y una salida al desempleo y el
desmoronamiento de los servicios
públicos dos años después la situación
sigue siendo precaria
los jóvenes son los más perjudicados en
este país especialmente por el gobierno
a nosotros nos mataron durante las
protestas y los recién licenciados están
en paro
más de 3400 candidatos compiten por 329
escaños en el parlamento en lo que son
los quintos comicios desde la invasión
estadounidense de irak en 2003